hallo freunde eventuell kennt ihr adobe
premiere pro hoffentlich könnt ihr es
nicht falls es noch nicht kennen das ist
ein videoschnittprogramm was ich
manchmal beziehungsweise sehr häufig
denkt ja ich stürze jetzt einfach mal ab
das ist ja nicht schlimm denn jetzt
haben sie seit kurzem diese zwischen
speicherfunktion das heißt alle paar
minuten kann man einstellen so das ganze
projekt zwischengespeichert werden jetzt
kam allerdings vor fünf oder sechs tagen
eine neue version auf die ach so toll
sein soll die 2015 auf 25 jahre edition
revierderby in dieser version soll alles
besser sein
denkste ich doch mehr erstmal so cool
sieht alles ein bisschen anders aus
bisschen special neue tolle bildchen hey
ich bin adobe das programm ist trotz mit
dauerhaft abgestürzt ich hatte immer
noch diesen quicktime fehler der alle
zehn mal kommt wenn man das programm
startet aber ich meine hey damit kann
ich leben ist ja nicht so dass ich dafür
unmengen an euros pro monat bezahlen
deswegen und nur deswegen arbeite ich
noch immer mit premiere pro einfach weil
ich keine zeit habe ein anderes programm
zu lernen
allerdings hat mir premiere pro heute
zuerst von der rest gegeben stellt euch
vor gearbeitet mega langen ein projekt
und ich bin ja auch ein youtuber der
jetzt nicht irgendwie für ein video zehn
minuten brauchen das einfach nur da rein
zieht sondern ich brauche man hier tun
es läuft design das war das hobby ihr
haupt änderungen 2015 ich sitze nicht
eine oder zwei oder drei minuten an
einem video sondern ich sitze schon mal
zwei oder drei stunden an einem gaming
video was ich dann so ganz toll
gearbeitet und so und dann kam heute
nach anderthalb stunden die meldung
die premiere wurde in der vorherigen
sitzung offenbar unerwartet geschlossen
möchten sie das letzte projekt öffne ich
natürlich ganz normaler und natürlicher
wie ich das neue projekt öffnen und neue
meldungen erzählt versucht das projekt
zu öffnen das resultat ist allerdings
nicht garantiert nicht garantiert ihr
habt diesen adapter kit entwickelt ihr
müsst mir garantieren können dass das
file noch funktioniert ich natürlich
auch okay gedrückt dann hier erst mal
schön das programm fall aus werde ich
habe jetzt mal irgendein projekt hier
geladen was kommt da auf einem
jung premiere pro hessen counter terror
als ich das zum ersten mal gelesen habe
dachte ich mir okay das ist premiere
ganz legale 2 minuten gegen den terror
klicks auf continue nachdem man dann
allerdings auf continuo gedrückt hat
kommt es ist ein schwerwiegender fehler
aufgetreten adobe premiere pro muss
beendet werden es wird versucht das
aktuelle projekt zu speichern danach
passiert dass hier das ganze lied ganz
kurz und wir sehen jeden moment adobe
premiere pro 2000 15.0 punktion nicht
mehr und dann hat man nur eine
möglichkeit nämlich das programm zu
schließen und jetzt wenn die eventuell
es liegt ein projekt oder wenn ich das
programm deinstallieren oder sonst
irgendwas mache
nein es kommt immer wieder dieser fehler
dass ich keine neue projekt sequenz
erstellen kann oder etwas anderes nicht
öffnen kann bei mir ist mittlerweile so
der punkt erreicht wo ich einfach sagen
ich glaube es hat mich ob ich verstehe
es nicht schlecht war wie kann ein
entwickler sagen das programm ist gut
und wir bringen die neue version raus
und gehen
nee ich verstehe es nicht so wie wenn
ihr dieses video seht euch an den kopf
und parkt dort ihren reihen es gibt
leute die mit diesem produkt täglich
arbeiten dann kann man nicht auf den
markt bringen wo nur fehler drin sind
meine fresse alter